hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca I'm Borderlands 3 again I
was gonna add this in the previous video
that I had just made about an hour ago
but I felt that this section of the
borderline show needed its own video and
its own talking to because that whole
thing had to do with the DLC this has to
do with the whole lot more and
specifically the questions and for some
odd reason like the people that asked
these questions are actually crazy and
I'm didn't I completely forgot about
half of the stuff that they had
mentioned so good props of the people
that had actually gotten their questions
answered so we're gonna be going over
those and you've probably seen it
somewhat in the title and we're gonna be
going over those right now so if you do
enjoy subscribe for new let's get
started so like I said during this
stream there was a questionnaire called
the mailbag and these were some of their
notable questions if you guys remember
on Pandora I believe it's the very
beginning area in the game that there is
this door that is like completely locked
we can't get into it there is a way to
get around it through the side but you
have to like jump it using one of the
vehicles it's a real big pain it's just
this empty area that no one really knows
people are speculating that there was a
raid boss there Randy Pitchford one of
the main developers of the game has
stated to not worry about the door at
the moment I mean he didn't actually say
anything specific but obviously he's
hinting at the fact that they're gonna
touch on that eventually I don't know
when that's gonna be but as for that you
know the door will actually come in
handy at one point maybe there will be a
raid boss I hope so I think that's a
really cool area that they should set
some stuff up there so that's a little
bit of a small question to that another
question somebody asked was about dr. Z
dr. Zed being one of the main characters
of the franchise and they asked where he
was throughout Borderlands 3 and I had
the same exact question to seeing as his
vending machine is still present in the
game and the problem doesn't actually
necessarily have to do with anything
in-game but actually out of game see all
the characters throughout Borderlands 3
in Borderlands 2 and you know in the
past as well have retained their voice
actors one of them that didn't retain
the voice actor I believe was claptrap
they had a new one they did they decided
to decline the recasting so they had to
get a new voice actor the voice actor
for said did not decline the invite to
recast his doctors ed but because he had
so many complications and a lot of
personal problems in real life that he
had to attend to he was actually not
able to make enough time to record voice
lines but apparently at this very moment
he's doing all good which is really nice
to hear and they do plan on doing stuff
later down the
so that does actually kind of confirm
that doctors that will be coming back to
the game
for what reason he'll be in maybe it's
something small just being a classic
vendor somewhere in a clinic at the main
area it's sanctuary or if he has like
his hone you know bunch of missions DLC
and stuff we'll have to see but anyway
doctors that come into the game is good
news regardless for me at my opinion and
then the last two questions have to do
with Elpis and Ava one of them is that
Elpis may or may not return to the game
if you don't know what Elpis is it's the
main setting where Borderlands the
pre-sequel is and I really feel like
Borderlands the pre-sequel didn't get
enough attention that it deserved and
obviously he's not going to spoil
anything cuz we've already learned way
too much information as we know already
what male 1 take down in DLC 1 with the
casino heist opus may in fact return
they do of course want to expand on the
universe the story the characters have a
lot of fun with it and just go balls
deep with it right so they do plan on
doing something with Elpis for what it
will be
they don't even know yet so who knows it
might just actually fall flat and that's
the issue we of course don't know what
it is and they don't even know what it
is either because they have barely even
started talking about Elpis probably
because they're working on a hell of a
lot more things currently that are
working presently in the game at the
moment and then the last thing is Ava
and the potential of getting an Ava DLC
Ava the character everybody loves to
hate because she's such an annoying
little brat but of course if you saw the
ending of the game it left a load of
different questions I'm going to spare
the details just in case you didn't see
the ending but if you did see the ending
for the game or anywhere like halfway
through the game you understand what's
happening with Ava and all this crazy
[ __ ] that's going on that needs
explanation of course it does so the
developers are probably going to look
into that maybe have maybe small
missions to add towards an Ava DLC or an
entire DLC revolving her maybe it'll be
one of those like a small event like the
bloody harvest where it's maybe a couple
missions like very similar to a
headhunter dlc in Borderlands 2 or an
entire story DLC like this up-and-coming
one with the casino heist but either way
I think regardless of how much I
actually dislike Ava I get that's the
entire intention of the character but
regardless of how much I hate her I
think a DLC for her to explain a few
things would be really cool because she
kind of just popped up out of nowhere
even though they kind of did explain the
upbringing in the origin of her she
really did just kind of pop out of
nowhere and then we just hated her
instantly okay guys that's going to be
the end
they say hopefully guys didn't enjoy
like I said I feel like this part needed
its own like video to talk about there
was a lot of things that we could
speculate there like I said we have a
potential Ava DLC Elpis might be
returning doctors that is probably the
most confirmed thing that we have
throughout this entire list as well as
the potential raid boss with the Pandora
Endor so that's gonna be super sick to
see I want to know your guys opinions
and all this stuff whether you would
want this in the game or not or hell if
you have any of your own questions or
maybe theories so let me know what you
guys think about the stuff in the
comments below I like to V if you're
doing joy subscriber free new peace out
guys I'll see in the next Borderlands
video goodbye
you